欢迎回来 希望你的大脑没有因为递归而栈溢出
第二部分会讲一些轻松的内容
具体来说 就是讲解一些练习题
在这章的网站上可以看到
第一节课中
我们捎带提到过使用 Haskell 实现快速排序（quicksort）
现在就详细地讲解一下快速排序的 Haskell 实现
快速排序的想法是递归地对列表排序
首先用某种方式将列表分解
再递归地排序这些列表
最后把结果结合到一起
如果仔细考虑一下可以发现
对于空表来说 已经排好序了
接下来进行递归
如何将列表分成两部分 来分别递归排序
并且可以很简单地把结果结合成一个排好序的列表呢
要做的是查看一下列表的头元素（head）
再把列表一分为二 一个是小于等于头元素的值组成的列表
另一个是大于头元素的值组成的列表
之后就可以递归地对两个列表进行排序了
最终将头元素插在中间 就结束了
这就是快速排序的算法精要
但我已经提醒过了
真正的实现中 不是创建新的列表
而是在原位改变（mutate）数据结构来交换元素
这在当前的实现中是没有体现出来的
但它的确展示了递归结构
好了 这就是快速排序的实现
它和第一节课的很像
唯一的区别只是名字叫 quicksort 而不是 f
遇到空列表时 它已经被排好序了
当遇到 x 连接（cons） xs 时 要排序的话
首先创建一个列表 使其元素都小于或等于 x
我们使用列表解析（list comprehension）来实现
接下来创建一个所有元素都比 x 大的列表
把两个都排序 再把 x 放在中间
这是一个很简单的快速排序实现
但同时 它也是一个简化了的快速排序实现
但如果是为了理解结构
这是一个很好的示例
可以体现其工作原理
让我们把快速排序记为 q
好让课件不至于溢出
如果要排序列表 [3, 2, 4, 1, 5]
要做的就是取头元素 3
再把列表剩下的元素 分成一组小于等于 3 的
还有一组大于 3 的
小于等于的是 1 和 2
大于的是 4 和 5
可以看到 递归排序两个列表
再把 3 插入到中间
如果要排序列表 [2, 1]
首先取头元素 再拆分剩下的列表 也就是 1
把它分成小于等于的值 以及大于的值
大于的列表是空表
小于的列表只有 1
再把 2 插入到中间
右边的同理
首先取第一个元素
再拆分剩下的列表 也就是 5
分成大于 4 的列表 也就是 5
小于的列表是空表
再把 4 插入到中间
这两个地方都是空表
已经排好序了 所以不用做任何事情了
接下来要对一个元素的列表进行排序
可以验证 对只有一个元素的列表进行排序 返回的是原列表本身
如果进行递归调用的话 就得到了这个列表
可以看到结果就是 [1, 2, 3, 4, 5]
只需要遍历一次树就可以得到结果了
这就是快速排序
本周有很多练习题 要求使用递归的方式定义函数
但现在就一起来看几个吧
首先来看第一个
要求生成一个列表 有 n 个相同的元素
也就是说 函数接收一个整数 n
再接收一个值 a
应当返回一个列表 其中 a 的值复制了 n 份
如何做到呢
解决的方法不是在 a 的值上递归
我们要建成一个列表
因此应该做的是在整数的结构上递归
所以同样分成两种情况
n 等于 0 把一个元素复制 0 份
得到的就是空表 这是个简单的情况
如果要把一个值复制 n 次 该如何做到
首先复制 n-1 次
得到一个列表 进行了 n-1 次复制
接下来把 a 连接（cons）到上面
这道题很容易
但同样的 需要仔细观察
之后就能发现 应该在这里进行递归
要分两种情况 把它们都写下来 剩下的也就知道了
下面这个我们在之前的课里也见到过
当时我提醒说 Haskell 中的列表没有常数时间的访问方法
实现这个函数时 就能清楚地明白了
要做的是 接收一个列表和一个数字 返回列表中那个位置上的元素
当然可以用 take drop 或其他函数来实现 但现在是要用递归
既然有两个递归结构
列表和整数
可以在两个上面一起递归来定义
那是怎么做的呢
首先如果要取列表的第 0 个元素
也就是列表的头元素
如果列表的形式是 x 连接 xs 并且这个参数是 0 的话
那这个元素就是答案 因为列表中第一个元素的下标就是 0
这个情况很简单
如果列表是空表的话
那该怎么办呢 这是个好问题
可能当我想要取一个空表的第 n 个元素
会产生一个错误
所以现在先不用考虑 放到最后一种情况再说
现在可以假设这个不是 0 这个不是空表
如果这个是 0 那就结束了
如果这个是空表 且这个不是 0 那就出错了
现在它们都不是 0 该怎么做
也就是说 这个是 x 连接 xs 这个是 n
要做的是取尾列表（tail）的第 n-1 个元素
也是简单的递归 只需要小心一下这些基本情况（base case）
最后要用递归定义的函数是
判断一个值是否在给定的列表中
当然我们可以作弊 不用递归
可以很容易地使用 filter （过滤）或者列表解析 或其他的
但现在的目标是用递归定义这个函数
这时很容易想到一个递归的候选 也就是列表
如果在空表中查找一个元素 返回的就是假
元素不在列表中
如果在 x 连接 xs 中寻找一个元素
需要检查列表的头元素是否等于要找的元素
如果是的话 那就返回真
否则的话 就在尾列表中查找那个元素
最终列表的尾列表（tail）将变空
回到基本情况 也就完成了
可以看到 这里在检查列表每一个头元素是否与这个元素相等 直到找到一个
类型 a 必须支持相等性（equality） 因此可以在类型中看到
要从一个列表中搜索一个值
只有当列表的类型支持相等性（equality）才可以
这就是为何此处要有约束（constraint） 要求 a 在类型类（type class） Eq a 中
好 希望这些有所帮助 这些小的练习
我说过 在网站上
还有很多使用递归的练习
如果卡住的话 试着吃根香蕉 也许能帮上忙
也可以吃两根
那帮助就更大了 下周再见